monkey can you show me how to put the
medicine straw on the baby
okay here here okay
okay let me see do it on mama how do you
do it
first i'll do i'll leave it here for you
so what's the first thing you do
no i don't know oh okay
oh he already cleaned me oh okay so you
clean my mouth
okay and then
the medicine straw
but where do you put it do you put it on
my skin or where does the medicine straw
go inside what it's in the teeth no
inside the balloon the blue line yes
okay okay good job
and then what happens yeah then what
happens
oh yeah and the medicine goes in
oh yeah get the medicine and then you
put it in there
good job
and then what happens
okay got the messy oh mama get sleepy
good night good night
so
don't be too alarmed but we're at the
hospital because
uh three weeks ago or maybe about a
month ago
look at this thing um tyka's teacher or
tech school called this one morning
they're like hey uh you're gonna have to
come pick up taika because we believe he
had a seizure
completely freaked out just the biggest
scare we've ever had absolutely that's a
real surreal moment
um
i the first thing i said when they
they said that i was like what
as i just have never dealt with that
besides briggy right but like in terms
of my family our family history our
health history that's also why it was
extra scary because brayden passed away
because of seizures yeah but i didn't
think about her in that moment oh i was
just i couldn't um i wasn't really
processing it other than i have to go
um
so i tell you the first thing you go
what the f yeah and then
i knew it i should have just cuz because
he knows that's about over yeah
so then uh yeah we've already picked him
up he's in the okay he's in the nurse's
like on a gurney type of thing or
there's bed yeah in his school yeah and
um he can't speak he doesn't recognize
that it's me
i'm balling his teeth like staff that
deals with him
on a daily
or interacts with him not deals that
interact with him is there and they're
crying they're trying to fight back
tears and i'm like what as high
what is happening
so i'm trying to comfort him he's
completely like discombobulated kind of
agitated a bit because of course he
doesn't know what's happening he can't
even talk
he's like ugh
um so
yeah he was completely discombobulated
uh paramedics come
they are asking the teacher questions of
like what happened so apparently he was
in line going from his home school like
his home classroom to i think like an
art class
and they're all in line outdoors
11am and uh
he falls
he shakes
he doesn't hit his head thank god
because i think the teachers that were
around she caught that and was able to
catch him before he hit his head yes
um the shaking she said happened for a
few seconds
and um they're asking if he was sick
because if there's high if he has a
fever then that that can cause a seizure
they asked what else did they ask i
can't remember like it runs in our
family
yeah like that um
so all of the things they were asking it
was just
that that could possibly lead to a
seizure he didn't have any of that
so now there's a bigger question of why
right so um they ask us if we should
ride in the ambulance and my thing that
i've always been told is no because it's
so expensive like don't do that we can
just drive them ourselves
but papa taking uh uh what is it life
and like a tactical trauma class
tactical trauma class he learned that
you should always get in the ambulance
because uh in case something does happen
they're already equipped and they can
take care of him so
uh in the event that he has another
seizure then
uh if he's in our car i wouldn't know
what to do other than you know probably
lay him on his side which i think i
eventually heard that's what you're
supposed to do you don't put anything in
their mouth um but if i'm driving and
papa's in the front seat like it's just
a recipe for disaster right right now
that's for medical professionals 100 so
then uh we opted to have him ride in the
ambulance he did
um i rode with him
he was
he could barely talk and i'm talking
about maybe
10 15 minutes after he had the seizure
um i'm sitting there in my thoughts and
trying to comfort him and going whoa
in a blink of an eye
life is so different right a baby could
have been gone or or he is gone at this
moment he is gone he's not talking he
doesn't recognize me he's
like it was just i was dealing with uh
an angry one-year-old again that could
barely speak
so i'm like holy crap okay so
i know they're doing their best but
paramedics are asking a ton of questions
because they're just trying to get all
this information so that they can relate
it to the er when we get there so we get
to the er
such a cool place um
they start running blood work oxygen uh
they run like oxygen not tests but like
they take his oxygen oxygen levels like
his vitals vitals thank you
whole blood blood sample yeah long story
short
it depends well
long story short medium um it depends in
the order of how these events occurred
that will determine
just from from looking at it if he had a
seizure or not so the doctor
was saying if he fainted
then led to a seizure he'll let that go
because um it's your brain basically
resetting yeah it's almost like the the
safer route kind of like when a boxer
gets knocked out and kind of like seizes
a little bit right when he hits the
ground right and they also said that
they tend to give a kid one seizure
um before they have to put them on
medication because i guess i've never
had one um but i guess that's just their
rule
of going hey before we load these kids
up on medication let's just see what's
going on um so that's just verbally what
they were able to tell us which is very
comforting because since then since a
month ago he hasn't had any episodes or
any abnormal uh behavioral traits
we haven't changed his life we haven't
changed his diet if anything he's
drinking water because they believe that
the fainting uh
may have been due to dehydration
um and he's been doing jujitsu too yes
so i didn't want to change any of his
play or anything because he already
knows that something's uh off
so verbally that's what they're able to
say but for everyone for the school to
feel comfortable for the er to feel
comfortable and for us as parents to
feel comfortable we're going to run more
comprehensive tests one of which is an
eeg
or ekg
eeg i forgot one of those e something
g's eeg yeah um and they're basically
going to study his way brain wave
pattern so one of the tests that they
ran is like i'll insert the video here
but uh they did a lot of like light
testing because that's what tends to
induce um seizures
so they did that they had him sit still
with like this
this skull cap on his head where he just
had to keep his eyes closed to avoid any
type of outside stimulation
um and they're gonna be read those brain
waves you're falling
[Music]
right now
um is
his mri test so um as tycho was
explaining they are going to put ivs
on the top of his hands
and we kind of just have to take it from
there
but
so far he's been the normal tyco we all
know
and love so crossing our fingers it was
just a faint that led to the brain reset
instead of
him having um
uh a life
with you know seizures
it's like a wax pencil yeah
why they made it red i don't know my
older masks
wax wax do you know like your your
crayons
it feels kind of like a crayon a little
bit
you probably wouldn't have picked such a
scary color
maybe it's so empty
that's okay that's all right go ahead
and look down with your whole head like
this yeah
look at your belly button
so this stuff i use in the beginning
it's sort of it's a salt-based
little scrub
except instead of for your heart it's
for your brain
so the things that stress the brain out
are things like light
breathing funny
he's borderline for that age-wise so we
try okay um but you know he's kind of
little so he might
he might
give it the good college try and then
stop okay okay so
taika i want you to keep your eyes
closed close and close and close them
close them close your eyes i want to
show you something exciting close them
keep them closed keep them closed mom
you can come over here
come close them okay dude
wiggle your head
there you go
see look at all those lines now close
your eyes
keep them closed keep them closed keep
them closed keep them closed keep them
closed
keep them closed
okay look how nice it looks now yeah
look at all those lines are going see
see how nice it looks so that's why we
have to keep our eyes closed it's very
important okay
so go ahead and close your eyes for me
now
all right mom we're going to record for
about two minutes okay
with just him hanging out
good job and then we'll look at some
flashing lights
really neat huh you can go home and tell
your friends you got to see your brain
doing its thing
so i will record for about two minutes
and then i'm gonna ice open your eyes
and look at the books
and you can close your eyes just as long
as you open them back up again okay
i know it's kind of rough but it's okay
open open close your eyes keep close
close close close close
your eyes
good
okay job open your eyes
and blink
[Music]
okay close your eyes
okay look for that snake in there is he
dancing nope oh let's see
do you see him in there yeah he's
dancing
close your eyes i think he caught on too
joke because he's like we're gonna keep
dancing very good
good job good job monkey monkey okay
open your
[Music]
eyes look at the box look at the box
good job
close your eyes nice
and slow oh
he gets faster
if you believe it open your eyes here we
go he's going to get faster go
whoa you look cool
good job
okay
what do you see out there duty let's see
engines
engines yeah let me see where where do
you see the engines look there oh yeah
you know what machines those are they're
for electricity electricity yeah are you
sure and for progress
sluggers are for this plug-in right here
yeah that connects to there to get more
electricity but the lipstick really
broke yeah then what do you do you can
turn it on anymore how are you so smart
how do you know these things i think
it's gonna turn off it's gonna be super
door you know what that's called
broken it is called broken but it's also
called a blackout when you don't have
any more electricity
but good thing all the pluggers are
working
yeah cause i don't want you to
kick off see
that broke
oh that one's broken yeah the door's not
on there right there
yeah look this thing i need to connect
who's gonna go fix it are you gonna go
fix it
disconnect the black things those things
someone needs to go fix the clothes
you know when you come into a hospital
it's actually like a pretty scary place
right you're always going through like
operations like you're not doing
anything fun
but i really like this children's
hospital because they do make it fun and
there's like all these like rockets and
stuff on the wall
there's planets there's planet earth
and even as you walk through the hallway
there's a lot of like cuny colors and
everything so
so far i really like this hospital and i
think that really adds to how comfy it
makes tycho feel like even this table
right here is full of jelly
beans so hopefully everything goes well
obviously me and margaret are the
parents we know what's going on so we're
super nervous i'm just so happy that
taika is in really really good spirits
and he's just
messing around so yeah
you can't get out the window dude
you can't get out the window you're
crazy
out of the little hole right there
are you gonna fit in there i think so
you know why you won't feel the shot
why because you got the magic lotion
look
you know what this does yeah i can keep
it like squishy oh don't squish it it
and it makes it numb so then you can do
anything you don't feel anything do you
feel your little hands do you feel me
touching your hands
no see yeah you put the magic lotion on
that means you're a superhero right now
why
well let me tell you dude that's a movie
and movies aren't real so if you fly if
you fall out this window it's all bad
news okay
[Music]
dude he's a practical spider-man
well you also need can you imagine the
spider-man walking around with the
ladder he's like i'm here to start
crying
[Laughter]
keeps you from barfing so you don't get
car sick on the way home and you can eat
and drink right away afterwards which
probably isn't an issue yet but by the
time we're done it will be okay and then
number three it's very quick on quick
off you literally give it 20 30 seconds
later you're asleep at the back end
you will be about
15 to 30 minutes
okay so it wears off pretty quick and
also we once we're done with the actual
mri we stop the medicine okay with
medicine and so you start the clock
starts ticking in there so quite often
they wake up within a few minutes after
you've seen it
he plays with you
oh we're taking stickers off
sit down
hold his arm
hold his body
yeah
look at those look at the ipad
good job
my friend will stand here she's going to
hold your other hand while you play with
this hand
can you drive your car
look at the car dude
there you go
[Music]
are you crashing all over the place he's
pretty good you're so silly he's getting
all the coins in there can you get him
we're trying to get that car over there
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
so what happened what is this
is your straw your medicine straw you
got all these medicines straws
it looks indestructible you can bounce
it around and stuff too yeah
and it's taped really nice you know you
look like a superhero look at this like
this wow
yeah
they're gonna put all these good
medicines in here
yeah what's the shot the shot's in here
yeah don't pull it out don't hold it up
don't touch them
yeah no there's no shut that's it you
did the shock that was it you did a good
job duty that's it yeah you did it
they just did it
what did it feel like monkey
it hurt a little bit i'm sorry but
you're so brave but you're done hey
don't don't mess with that but you don't
know you're so brave duty
the medicine's strong yeah the blood
goes in here
[Music]
like that yeah
they had to test it to see if the blood
goes in and out
okay
hey
[Music]
do you see another exit sign over there
a salad yeah
okay i have a question for you yeah but
not too much because that's vlog correct
hey i have a question for you
so if you ever want to go outside what
what sign do you follow
to go outside
exit good job these guys this one's
gonna tell you hey listen to me these
signs if you follow it it's gonna tell
you how to go outside okay hey so
anytime you see it wait i know i know no
that one's telling you to stop yeah it
tells you can't go there this right here
says you can't go there either see the
bumblebee line you can't go past the
bumblebee line
monkey sometimes you'll when we go to
stores you gotta look for these okay
don't put it in your eyes dude
you're gonna do awesome have fun
i'll be right here okay
so they just put taika to sleep and even
that
feels really weird to say
because i'm used to only putting animals
to sleep and that's a euphemism for
making them go to the next life
and man i don't know if any of you guys
have ever seen like your kid get sedated
but it's one of the scariest things like
yeah it's only like 10 seconds
so we bring them we bring them in you
know and he's holding my hand and he's
tight and he's scared of course and you
see all these big like mri machines
and then they lower the bed and they say
okay time to get on and immediately you
see tyka's face go
i'm so nervous i'm like it's okay monkey
it's okay monkey we help him get on the
bed and we lay his head in that big
plastic thing where his head's supposed
to stay still in
and i'm like stroking his arm and i'm
like petting his face trying to help him
relax
and then uh they put the iv in and um
they put the the medicine in
and they did tell us that the medicine
feels like ants going up his arm
so as soon as they started mentoring the
medicine at first tiger didn't have a
reaction so i was like okay cool like
he's just gonna go to sleep and then all
of a sudden he goes i'm burning i'm
burning my arms burning and then so that
the two nurses had to hold on to his
legs i had to hold on to his arm and he
was like squirming around while the
doctor's trying to keep his his hand on
him because i think tyco's gonna pull
the medicine out
and that whole like fight was very like
heart-wrenching especially for like a
pops you know
and then you just see him go
like eyes roll to the back of his head
and i just never seen him fall asleep
like that or fall asleep like that and
i'm like oh my god like that oh it just
sucks that he has to go through all this
and there's a side of both me and geo
we're like [ __ ] man why don't all these
goddamn procedures he's only four
and yes we know like the logical side
it's yeah we want to go through all
these procedures because you know as as
geo was explaining earlier
we need to figure out did he have a
seizure
and then he passed out or did he have a
did he pass out and then you have a
seizure and the only way to determine
that is do all these scans to see if
there are any abnormalities in his heart
and his brain and his lungs and all that
so i know like scientifically logically
like this is good for him so we rule out
any uh variables but as a parent seeing
your
like kid go through
any type of like quote-unquote even
medical torment
doesn't feel good you know so um now
it's the waiting room face
i have to wait about 20 30 minutes and
then we'll get
an update and we'll see the pictures of
his brain and see if it's
if he's good or if he has any
abnormalities hopefully
there's lit i can't even cross my
fingers on this side hopefully there are
none and he's just a perfect
healthy boy and it was just one day of
him not drinking enough water and he's
dehydrated and then
he passed out
so the duty did well but as you can see
he is out
so now we just have to wait for the
medicine to wear off
how are you feeling judy he's high
are you loopy mr duty he says he's a
little dizzy you got yummy popsicle
that must be delicious
oh you could definitely you could
definitely tell he's not his normal self
it's a bit loopy yeah a little bit but
i'm glad you're awake mister
what do you want to eat for lunch
something yummy nothing right now you
can't have anything yet oh you can't no
he might throw up oh when can we eat we
can eat something you want him to drink
first just slowly introduce stuff back
into his system like a big fat milkshake
just kidding those are the mom eyes if i
ever saw one
you big candy
yeah we will okay papa's gonna get the
car okay monkey okay stay right here i
love you
so i ran all the way to the car because
obviously i don't want tyka to walk
nor do i want jio to carry his big ass
because he's pretty heavy he's almost 50
pounds now
it's around all the way over to the car
and that was the first time i got to see
him
since the sedation because uh because
the culvert rules you can only have
one guest per patient and that guest has
to be
a family member so i was just in the
hallway just kind of like sneaking looks
and every time like the main door open
until finally like a nurse came i was
like sir you can't be waiting in the
hallway you have to go in the waiting
areas i was like all right fine but i
was just so nervous you know like i just
want everything to go good so
i'm so excited and so happy to see that
taika is in good spirits
and i don't want them to wait any longer
so i'm gonna pull the car to the front
it's so heavy you're 45 pounds dude
i like seeing his little black fuzz head
can you stand up or not yet can you
stand up mr man
you got it
comfy he's comfy bushy see can you stand
up
good job there you go whoa
okay
ready
you okay oh he's tired
one two three good job duty
so proud of you mr red sox
look at him
what face did you make
to papa to peppa
slowly coming back
so earlier when i was saying that i
learned in the tactical trauma class
that it's better to have an ambulance
take whatever patient to the hospital
or trauma victim to the hospital beside
yourself and the reason that we learned
is there's all types of infrastructure
already put in place
when you call 9-1-1 like one you already
prepped them to give all kinds of
information they brief the ambulance guy
when they come of course when i ask you
all the same information so like in a
state of anxiety and high stress you're
gonna be like why why are you gonna ask
me the same question i told everyone and
it's because every step of the way they
want to confirm to make sure okay it's
indeed this patient it's indeed this is
what they need to get treated
but when they're in the ambulance
they're already phoning the er letting
them know what type of patient to
accept so it could be a gunshot wound
patient it could be someone that drank
uh like a poison like a clorox or
whatever so they're already ready
depending on how heightened the
emergency is and that's why it's so
important so when we're at the
elementary school
and they're like do you want them to
roll with the ambulance or you want to
take them i'm like no take them in the
ambulance i don't know if he's going to
have another one because we don't know
what kind of seizure he had and then
that way they can treat them right on
the spot
and if there's a huge huge huge
emergency god forbid and they need to do
something where they need to like shoot
them straight to like the icu or
something like that
all of that infrastructure is put in
place so mama rode with taika in the
ambulance and i just trailed behind
uh
in the regular car so
that's something that i learned in that
class it's very useful
take us back home feeling a little bit
better
he's still a little loopy
she hasn't eaten anything since last
night what what time would you say
i don't know
that you
may be like seven seven seven thirty
yeah
so uh i'm just giving him
whatever cookie these are chocolate
graham crackers your regular graham
crackers and then some like butter
not butter but like just crackers
um
to introduce food back to his diet for
those together i want to like taste oh
you want to trace them together yeah see
what they taste oh okay i'll do that i
think the dude is back this guy's
experimenting not yet did you see when
he tried to reach over his head he's top
heavy right now
careful careful don't move so fast i'll
give it to you
are you eating the crumbs off the couch
oh my goodness
all right i think this guy's back
this guy's back in business
he's singing sunflower he's eating
crumbs off the couch
this is the taika i know
oh jesus monkey a lot of people fart on
that couch
on that couch
and there's a lot of butt butt juice on
there butt juice
did he just spray all those crumbs back
in your face
[Music]
tell papa what you just said
what'd you just say monkey why is your
hair standing so high
[Music]
is
frosting yeah that's disgusting
this dude is still loopy but look at him
no
no first oh you're gonna do it to me
yeah
[Music]
all right and then i drafter you're so
loopy still
you ready
[Music]
all right so taika wants to play for
real for real and now i told them wait
hold on a second wait hold on a second i
want to make sure he passes a couple of
coordination tests because i don't want
him falling off the couch so show me
show me you can walk forward let me see
okay
okay so you got good balance that's good
can you do it backwards let me see
okay
now for the ultimate test let me see
your front flip
okay do it on the couch let me see
all right
what do you think mom you think he's
ready to have unrestricted play
yes
all right the little duty is back
did you catch me no
because i was in your burger yeah cause
i was opening these guys and i'm like oh
what's a monster two and i was like
three and i picked it and it's pretty
heavy
what happened
are you tripped you okay
come here come here duty
you got it
okay
um and they're pretty
smart
i'm sorry
i'm sorry so when i got this one i
thought there were more tater tots today
i opened it and i was like oh it's so
cute
this is yours it's your cutie little
booger little boogie boogie i'll smash
your book
all right so we got some food
super happy that taika is in really good
spirits because it started off as a
kind of like a sad somber day you know
but i'm glad that everything feels good
now taika's back to normal and we got
yummy food so we'll see you guys
tomorrow